when Stefani and Blake Shelton are  returning to the place where they fell  in love the voice we can make each  others  Gwen sat out as a coach this season with  Miley Cyrus and Alicia Keys joining  Blake Shelton and Adam Levine on the  show it's good we have a good  camaraderie but Tuesday morning it was  announced that Stefani will return for  season 12 that will debut in February  Blake will be back too though that's not  really a surprise he's never missed a  season watch The Voice staple Adam  Levine will also return for season 12 as  will Alicia Keys Miley Cyrus is out but  NBC says she'll coach again on season 13  in fall 2017 this will be Gwen's third  time coaching on the show though she has  yet to win we're rootin for you Gwen  what do you think like  you